we begin with a series of deadly storms
hammering the West Coast causing massive
flooding and widespread power outages
affecting tens of thousands of people
around 90 percent of the state's
residents are under flood watches this
morning Carter Evans is in Santa Cruz
County in the northern part of the state
Carter good morning
good morning we're seeing a break in the
rain right now in this Santa Cruz area
but this neighborhood as you can see is
just inundated with flood water over the
last couple of weeks California has seen
quadruple its normal rainfall and right
now thousands of people up and down the
coast are facing mandatory evacuation
orders
California needs water but not like this
this
besieged by weeks of powerful storms the
ground here is saturated that's leading
to landslides
and debris flow
in Los Angeles County torrential
downpours opened up this sinkhole
overnight it swallowed two occupied cars
firefighters had to use ladders to
rescue the driver and a teenager from
the 15-foot pit
in San Luis Obispo County at least one
person died when their car was overtaken
and a five-year-old boy went missing
during a rescue believed to have been
swept away in Santa Cruz County the San
Lorenzo River quickly climbed to a major
flood stage we've been out of power just
got it back on for only one day to lose
it again mud-soaked hillsides are
sliding down this one blocked the
highway into town it's like a like a rat
trying to get out of a maze trying to
find the different little route to get
through this is crazy
Ellen DeGeneres is one of thousands of
Santa Barbara County residents facing
mandatory evacuation orders this
Preston is there here in Montecito
family spent Monday evacuating the
coastal city as incessant rain pounded
the area the 101 a major highway here in
California is shut down because of
flooding like this shelters are open for
families to stay safe back in Northern
California High Surf slammed Waterfront
businesses in Capitola so this
restaurant's been in the family for
decades have you ever seen damage like
this before
I have not kitchen manager Josh Whitby
says it'll take months to rebuild
right now they're hoping to be back in
business by Memorial Day in the meantime
Coastal neighborhoods like this one in
central California are facing a high
surf warning with the potential for
waves get this up to 25 feet today Gail
boy Carter California having a very
tough time thank you so much